So, and I have a quiz, to see if you can figure out, either through experiments,
or logic alone. But probably you'll want to do some experiments. How default
parameters work and why there's certain pitfalls to using them. One issue some
people have with the provided list depend method, is that it doesn't actually
return anything. It's a really common mistake to assign to p the result of
p.append. In this case, while p.append modifies the value of p, but it doesn't
return the list p, it returns none. So after this the value of p will be none,
which is probably not what we want. There are lots of situations where we might
want to use append in this kind of functional way. We might want to pass in the
result of appending to a new function. So I'm going to try to define a function
that does that. So I want a function, my-append, that behaves like this. If we
call it with just one parameter, it'll create a new list containing that as the
only element. If we call it like this, passing in two parameters, the first one
being orange, the second one, the result of my-append apple. Well then, what we
would like to get is a list containing the elements apple and orange. This will
allow us to write code in a fairly compact way. So we could try to define
my-append like this using a default parameter. This seems to almost work. So
here, we'll call my-append as shown above. And we do indeed get the list apple,
orange as desired. But there's something really broken about this code. And I
want to see if you can figure out what it is. You may need to do a few
experiments to figure that out, but it should all make sense once you think it
through. Here are the choices. The default parameters initialized to empty list,
but default parameters can only be None. The second choice is the default
parameters initialized when the function is first called, and then, that same
value is reused each time. And the third choice is default list parameters
initialized when the function is defined and that same object is reused for each
call. See if you can figure out which is the reason this code doesn't behave as
desired.